the russia hoax is now unraveling as
much as ever in the deep state
is on the defensive friday senator
lindsey graham south carolina his
judiciary committee released
declassified documents showing what we'd
been reporting the fbi not only had
serious doubts about the claims made in
christopher steele's
dirty russian dossier of misinformation
that hillary paid for
by the way white house chief of staff
mark meadows says it's time for
indictments he's right the
time is coming take a look well
i think the american people expect
indictments i know i
expect indictments based on the evidence
i've seen
lindsey graham did a good job in getting
that out you're going to see
a couple of other documents come out in
the coming days
that will suggest that not only was the
campaign spied on
but the fbi did not act appropriately as
they were investigating
remember we now know that by early 2017
the fbi knew without any doubt
whatsoever that dossier hillary paid for
with russian lies and comey mccabe the
rest of the deep state
they kept using it for one fisa
application after another they knew it
was false premeditated fraud
now we learn friday peter strzok appears
to have realized
well a deep state day of reckoning was
on the horizon as
the disgraced fbi agent lashing out
through his lawyer at senator graham
following the latest revelations here
with more senator lindsey graham
you know senator i guess uh you know
we know that they were worn before the
first fisa
uh application right we know mccabe said
without the dirty dossier
there would be no fisa warrant issued
right
he said that to the house intel
committee now we know that kathleen
kavlak we know that bruce ohr warned
them before the first one
they signed it then we had a sub source
in january
say uh no that was all bar talk
now you have a new document mostly
unredacted there's a little too many
redactions for my liking tell us what
you found
well i found a memo that was uh put
together after the interview with the
russian subsource
you said it well sean without the russ
the russian dossier
they couldn't obtain a warrant they
tried to get a fisa warrant against
carter page
and it was rejected they find the
dossier and all of a sudden they get a
warrant
horowitz said without the dossier
there's no warrant
so from january 24th to january 27th
the fbi interviews the russian
sub-source who put the dossier together
they created a 40-page memo showing it
was a bunch of garbage
not reliable at all here's the question
how could it be that they continue to
use the dossier in
april and june of 2017
knowing that in january the dossier was
completely discredited by the person who
put it together
here's the question for me did the intel
analyst who wrote the memo
tell anybody up the chain oh by the way
our case just fell apart
i find it almost impossible to believe
that the senior people at the fbi
were not told that in january 2017
the case fell apart against carter page
okay now if that's the case now i don't
know
you're the attorney lindsay but that now
confirms completely even struck you
but they did it anyway americans when
they lie to a court and they know
they're lying to a court
you should go to jail to get a warrant
the court relies on
affidavits signed by law enforcement
officials so on
august the 5th i'm calling sally yates
she was the number two at the justice
department
on august the 5th she will come before
our committee and i appreciate her
voluntarily coming
remember on january the 4th 2017 the fbi
agents
involved in on the ground said let's
drop flynn from crossfire hurricane
we found no evidence at all that he was
working with the russians
let's take him out of the investigation
that's when strzok tells those people no
the seventh floor wants to keep going
so the next day january the 5th they
meet with president obama and vice
president biden
to continue to surveil uh general flynn
and here's what's shocking sally ace the
number two at the justice department did
not even know they were following flynn
but obama did
and here's three things i want to ask
her if you knew then what you know now
would you have signed the warrant
application against carter page
did you hear joe biden say what about
the logan act when it comes to general
flynn
and is it true that you were surprised
the president knew about the
surveillance of flynn and you did not
we already know the answers to all those
uh senator graham
here's the next step though in all of
this we haven't heard it yet
okay but we we know she we already know
from what we knew about the
the january fifth meeting but they
didn't she hasn't she
hasn't testified in a person but she
will soon
i am told that we now believe we have
found
not only the person that was the main
source for the
dirty russian steele dossier you're
smiling that means i'm probably over the
target
and i've also heard that there are
people that are good
the 99 within the
fbi community the world's premier law
enforcement agency and the cia the
world's premier intelligence agency
the 99 percent of good people they're
now beginning to talk
and they're beginning to tell about
stories that they
warned everybody not to do certain
things and they were ignored
which means that's even worse than we
thought
the walls are closing in people are
beginning to talk remember in the
affidavit somebody told the court the
subsource the russian guy was truthful
and cooperative
nothing could have been more untrue than
that he was
truthful but he destroyed the
reliability of the dossier
they misled the court if you can find
the person who said that
you're off to the races it's impossible
they wrote this 40-page memo and didn't
share it with people at the top
and here's what peter strzok said in
february 2017.
again we're unaware of any trump
advisers engaging in conversations
with russian intelligence officials this
is in february 2017.
here's a question why the hell was
mueller appointed to begin with
if in february they had no evidence of
trump officials talking to the russians
working with them
what happened between february and may
of 2017.
lindsey graham by the way i'm so sorry
to hear i know
rosie o'donnell and barbara streisand
and hillary clinton that donated
millions to your opponent
i know the people of south carolina
could be very influenced by the millions
of barber streisand and rosie and
hillary i you know i'm really worried
about that for you
all right senator thank you very much
for your concern thank you
so concerned